Here are examples of some popular and representative component models.
First off, from the Sun Microsystems, now Oracle Enterprise Solution,
there are Enterprise Java Beans also called EJB.
Included in this is J2EE and JSP, which is Java Server Pages.
Of course, they compete with Microsoft and
Microsoft offers COM, which is the component object model,
DCOM, the distributed COM, OLE, ActiveX, and COM+ for transactions.
Microsoft also offers .NET and
in .NET there were technologies such as the common language infrastructure, CLI,
and the common language runtime, CLR, and ASP.NET.
An older component technology is CORBA and its component model is called CCM.
CORBA itself stands for the Common Object Request Broker.
And it comes from the Object Management group.
It includes an Object Management Architecture and
an Interface Description Language called IDL.
Finally and more generically, there's web services.
These include web service description language, WSDL, Universal Description,
Discover and Innovation markup, also called UDDI.
And the Simple Object Access Protocol SOAP.